what script did you sell for a million
dollars
wow um so the script I sold for a
million dollars was something called
Stanley's cup and this is like at this
point it's kind of like ancient history
it was 1995 and I was approached by a
producer who um had this idea for a
hockey movie and they
he went to a another writer who was not
available so you know I guess my agent
at that time felt I had a similar
writing style to the writer he really
wanted and so he agreed to develop it
with me so we developed it out together
and
um you know and then kind of
I remember reading it before
doing the big distribution and I had
this weird experience I I uh read the
script and got teary at the end at the
climax of My Own Story which really
doesn't happen that much so I mean maybe
yeah while watching my Bar Mitzvah video
I'll get a little weepy but the but
while reading the script generally I I'm
not affected that way and I went oh I
think I might have something here
because it just it
you know it just touched me in some
weird way even though I had literally
just finished the script I was just
rereading it so uh so we went out with
the script and
um like almost immediately started
getting interest it's like we went out
with the script on a Tuesday
um and almost immediately started
getting interest and it was kind of by
Thursday night there was an offer on the
table from
um I believe it was from Disney
for 250 thousand dollars
which was
you know more money than I'd ever seen
in my entire life and then I'd been
working for the previous couple of years
so I was I was a working screenwriter at
that time but I hadn't sold a spec so so
250 000 at in one chunk seemed like a
really swell idea to me and I get a call
from my agent
um this is on that Thursday night who
says
he goes I don't think you should take it
I went really he goes I think there's
more money out there
I went okay so I just talk it over with
my wife you know it's like and go
you know we're gonna say no to 250 000
and she's like okay you know let's do
this so they turned it down and then the
next day I was getting like phone calls
like every 25 30 minutes it's like it's
now an offer for three there's an offer
for 375 that's an offer for 450 and it
just kept going up until it finally hit
eight hundred thousand dollars
um against a million one so you know in
the business that's considered a million
dollar
spec sale
um because if the movie had gotten made
there would have been that extra 300 000
that have wrote it up to a million one
and finally my agent says I think this
is the offer to take and the crazy part
about it was that the um the company
that
finally got it
um was a division of Disney so Disney
was basically bidding against Disney and
like bidding it up so I was like okay
that works for me but uh yeah that was
like that Friday night you know went to
bed going that was a pretty good week
yeah that was a very exciting week you
don't get weeks like that uh very often
but um but and and not to not to be a
cold bucket of water on my own story but
I remember going to bed that night going
oh
I'm done that's great I don't have to I
don't have to hustle anymore I don't
have to you know I felt like you know
really made it end the the truth of it
is that yeah I gotta bump a little bit
like then like on the heels of that
immediately got another job just because
I was sort of the flavor of the month
kind of thing
um but it you know you think you sell a
spec screenplay and you know you've made
it it's not a career that's just a very
lucky job but it's not a career so so
there's still a lot of career building
to be done which I didn't appreciate as
a young youngish writer selling a big
Spectrum player like that but um but it
it didn't suck
would it teach you about sort of knowing
your worth because it sounds like you
were very close to taking the 250 000
yeah
so
I don't know that it taught me anything
about knowing my worth because like
anybody who knows me knows that I've
overestimated my own worth
pretty much from infancy so so I just
felt like it's all about what the market
will bear kind of thing like you know
like if if that screenplay was available
today would that ever be an 800 000
against
1.1 million screenplay I doubt it
um it's just it just changed but at that
period of time
it was
that's what screenplays was selling for
it was I mean people if they want to
look up a little bit of film history
look up like spec sales from you know
mid 1995 and you'll see it started with
um cable guy really
um and that sold for I think 750 000
um and that suddenly became sort of the
Touchstone even to the point where my
agent said when somebody said what's it
going to take to take this script off
the market and the response was Cable
Guy money so that that became and there
was just this rash of spec sales at that
time I think Joe Esther house
um sold something for four million
dollars and Shane black I don't know if
that was that was before or after last
Boy Scout or um long kiss good night but
it was it was one of those that also
sold for like two million you know so it
was like it was getting into crazy crazy
numbers
um at that period of time so I always
felt that my value is fine and you know
it's just what
people are willing to spend on it I mean
I've had scripts since then that I feel
are just pound for pound much better
it's just as far as conceptually and as
far as the story goes and and depth and
my own ability as a writer and just
never sold
right so it's like you never know so you
know so if I if I if I
Define my worth based on a piece of
material then that particular Friday
when I went to bed you know my value
would be really high and the Fridays
that I went to bed when I didn't sell
something that week my value would be
low I don't know my value is consistent
it's just what people are willing to to
pay for it and Things Come and Go I mean
it's like I had a script that I wrote
literally in
1989 that didn't get made until uh
2006. so 16 years from the time I wrote
it and it was a good script
who knows but you can't for sure you
cannot if you if you let the if you let
the
you know vague
sense of yeah I'm only my worth is only
defined by my material you'll
you know you'll want to get out of this
business really quickly
how does payment generally work when a
screenwriter sells a screenplay ah it
it's a very it's a very fun day because
um it takes about a couple weeks you
know between the time because you sell
it and then business Affairs now has to
hash out all the contractual bits and
pieces of it and so that's a couple of
weeks worth of work and then once the
contracts are all signed then just
somebody usually your agent says we have
a check here for you because
um and then you get you know you see all
the deductions come out you know it's
like you know it's it feels like if I
said oh yeah the the selling price was
800 000 on that spec screenplay on
Stanley's cup but um I
forget how much the check was four but
20 this is 25 percent came off
immediately off the top yeah 10 to a
manager 10 to age and five to my lawyer
right and uh you know so you start going
you know okay so that came off and then
I think I think I was still like a W-2 I
don't I don't know if I had a my loanout
company at that time so now taxes come
out anyway you end up with probably by
the time you get done
30 percent of of the thing so it's a
little heartbreaking but still it's
still a lot of money you know it's like
you know you get a check like that and
um I remember picking up the check I was
with William Morris at the time and
remember picking up the check from them
and like walking it over to the bank to
deposit it because I didn't even want to
like I didn't even want to
like carry it home and then go to the
bank later I just want to go right from
there to this other than nothing could
nothing would happen to it so um yeah
it's just it's a it's a it's a pretty
straightforward
you know um process with the exception
that you know you don't often hold a
check that has so many zeros on it
what did this experience teach you about
the
experience of selling a big spec
screenplay like that
really kind of taught me that it's a
I mean it's everything you think going
into it and then it's sort of
processing it afterwards so going into
it you think like I was saying before
great I've made it I don't have to worry
anymore right and then afterwards you go
oh no I actually still have to come up
with stuff people aren't going to keep
handing me things to do just because I
sold the screenplay once and um it just
taught me that it's you constantly have
to hustle and and not be afraid to
reinvent yourself and generate ideas
um one of my one of the agents that I
had at that time
um had what I still think is
kind of cynical yet might be really
accurate good advice
um when I was asking like what should I
work on next and he goes he goes I don't
know but make it derivative and make it
quick
that ID you just have to it's I mean
occasionally like yeah I haven't I
haven't taught
screenwriting in seminars for a while
but when I did I would usually start
with
asking everybody who is coming to hear
me talk
um like how long does it take you to
write a screenplay and I'll go you know
if it takes you you know everybody takes
you know uh three months raise your hand
and you know a couple of hands would go
up right you have six months you know
more hands would go up right you know
eight months to a year you know probably
that's where the bulk of the hands went
up and I said
anyone who did not raise your hand for
three months you're probably not going
to make it in the business
because you don't have time if you if
you want to make it if you if you want
to
have a career
it's going to take you
10 years of slugging away at it you know
slogging away at it to launch a career
and if you're writing one screenplay you
know every year it's like okay well that
great that was 10 screenplays but you're
not going to get any good until you get
to your seventh or eighth screenplay
anyway
so
just bang them out you know like learn
something from every screenplay so make
it and make a derivative at that time
just meant you know oh uh you know
there's a movie that you really liked
from 10 years ago you know if there's
something derivative from that that
still speaks to you you should work on
that but also don't work on it for a
year just paying it out so I mean I was
I was you know at that period of time
just trying to be a machine I mean I I'd
be cranking three four scripts a year
specs yeah just because you just had to
keep it's like buying lottery tickets
right it's like you know buy one lottery
ticket hey buy 100 lottery tickets you
got maybe a greater chance statistically
so every screen plays a lottery ticket
so so that's kind of like what I I
learned from it is that yeah just you
know constantly have to hustle you can
feel good about yourself for a little
bit after some success and you want to
take the successes you want to feel good
about yourself but but don't let the
successes Define you or take you off
your guard or make you feel you know
lazy you know or you know ah you know I
don't have to do anything anymore no
constantly have to do stuff
in some sense did it almost create more
pressure
because now more is expected of you no
interestingly
it
and this is going to be kind of a weird
thing to say
if I had it all to do over again knowing
what I know now
um I would have preferred not to sell a
spec screenplay
money goes away that doesn't last what
you want to do is build a career so what
happens
or in my experience as a result of
selling that spec screenplay it
artificially I was I was a solid writer
at that point I you know I think I
worked on on the like the very first
thing I did was like a script doctoring
gig
um for
um uh the amazing panda adventure for
Warner Brothers that was like the first
real paying oh no that wasn't that
wasn't the first paying me the first
paying thing I did was
um was actually I got paid to write
Bloodsport too right but that was you
know kind of like not a major studio
type of thing
um but it got me into the guild but the
first Studio job that I had uh was for
Warner Brothers and for the amazing
panda adventure and I think I paid forty
thousand dollars for like two weeks of
work which is even today that's doesn't
suck right but I think it was forty
thousand dollars for two weeks of work
as a script doctor right because they
like my dialogue and you know they
needed a dialogue polish on it so I did
that then they like the work so much
that I got
um I was the first writer on Dennis the
Menace II right and that paid 90 000.
right so in the banana and that was
two months of work or so right so you
know and then I think after Dennis the
Menace II I think I optioned something
for not a lot of money oh but then I got
then I got hired to
um to
I don't say script doctor but to do a
pass on what turned into an Olsen twins
movie It Takes Two so I was like the
second writer on them I don't have a
credit and we can discuss the joys of
writer's Guild arbitration at some point
if you'd like if I didn't get a credit
on that one but that paid 150 000. so
like I I was I was sort of like building
like my quote was going up organically
and naturally and then from 150 jumped
to 800 000 so that artificially inflated
my quote because now it's like my agents
are in this weird situation where it's
like well you know we want you have to
work on on the screenplay what's his
quote and you can't say well 175 you
know like or 200 because of the last
quote you know the quote now gets
artificially inflated so I'm sure there
were a number of jobs that were just was
they would have been happy to pay 250
but not happy to pay five or seven fifty
or something like that you know what I
mean so
so in a weird way
it kind of priced me out of the market
um you know and then I had to take a
step back and
you know and kind of sort of re-jig you
know my career and say let me look at
television also let me like expand so
you know so it was kind of I don't want
to say that that selling the spec was
the worst thing that ever happened to me
it clearly wasn't but with the benefit
of hindsight and a little bit more
knowledge of how the business
works it was like
you know I don't know but then I'm sure
there were plenty of people out there
who you know come from nowhere sell a
big spec and
you know just
yeah that's their you know that becomes
their
career path and and it's all fine I
think what I think what really
what didn't help the most if that's the
way to put it is that the fact that the
movie never got made you know had the
movie gotten made and it was a hit that
that changes one's career trajectory so
this was was purchased it it was it had
a um
a very uh
specific time frame with which it had to
go into production
um like it was purchased in May and it
was supposed to go into production by
October it had Dennis Leary attached to
Star and Chris Farley as the co-star
um just really is sort of a weird kind
of sports comedy about the Stanley Cup
going missing right so um so I had
Dennis Leary and Chris Farley and the
director was Jim Abrams you know um from
you know airplane and you know the
Zucker you know Abrams team
um so it had like all the elements in
place to be fast-tracked into production
but but Jim Abrams was going through a
dark period in his life because he had a
son who was uh very ill
um so he was like very who I think the
sun is fine or was fine you know
afterwards but he he really wanted to
make it less of a silly comedy and get
me like more serious of it so they hired
some other writers to come in after me
and they did a draft and it became kind
of very serious and Studio didn't like
it they liked the the funnier version of
it but now it's like it's gone down and
they paid those guys 500 I'm a 500 500
000 to rewrite the screenplay that they
already paid you know eight hundred
thousand dollars for and then it became
sort of unusable and so then they were
in the process of going back to say okay
let's kind of go back to what we like
um and then Chris Farley passed this
away and then so it was like this sort
of domino effect of just
ill-timed Fortune
um so had it gotten made I think sort of
the lessons would have been potentially
different but um well I love where you
took it at what point did you realize
this isn't happening
um when I I as a courtesy I was sent to
the rewrite of the script
um and um and I read it I went
I just felt that everything in my gut
that this thing is just not not
shootable
um it it was I mean the script was I
mean at the risk of sounding like an old
TV guy thing it was like a zany comedy
you know you know road trip comedy you
know with hockey's Stanley Cup and this
and the rewrite turn to like no joke
basically into rain man
um you know you know they turned it into
like a my zany comedy turned into like a
serious exploration of the problems of
the mentally ill you know I was like you
know you couldn't have gone more
different I'm going
who wants to see this I mean it was like
so at that point I was going okay I
think we're in trouble here and then and
then there's sort of a cascading series
of events from there
why do you use Forex story structure
instead of three act story structure
um because I'm Jewish
because you know it's the four Suns the
four cups of wine the four acts it's
it's every every Passover we sit at the
table and we drink another cup of wine
to each one of the acts I'm kidding stop
it it's a joke okay
um but I wasn't kidding I am Jewish the
um
I found it to be an easier way of
of just thinking it's just it makes
things balanced you know like three acts
you know on a typical three-act
structure it's act two is twice as long
as act one and act three so why not just
call it 4X already so you can have like
act one act two a act 2B and then you
know and then act three I mean I used to
I think in the early days when I was
working on the system I think that's how
I was calling it and then that just felt
confusing so I just went to a thing you
know act one two three and four so it's
a 4X structure but it's all the same I
mean it's it's all you know three-act
structure I forget who it could be truby
does a six act structure said Fields
three acts it's like you know it's we're
all talking about the same stuff it's
really just here's your pie you're gonna
slice it into eighths or sixteenths or
whatever so you know and then and then
other pieces of of my understanding of
story structure played nicely with the
four acts so you know the the four
archetypes you know things like that so
it just felt like Forex made things kind
of brought a nice order to the universe
did anybody fight you on it or no she's
like people like me all the time but I
mean in terms of didn't they say that
can't be done it's always you know and
you said sure why not why it's 2A to be
and no it yeah it's it's like and every
every conversation I have like that is
always
just silly I mean I mean I I it happens
now it's where like I'll talk to people
who are working on
on like um TV shows like um you know
even even like a um
like an episode of Television where it's
it's every story has got a beginning a
middle and an end so at the very least
you can subscribe to a three-act
structure for your TV show but people
say well but we don't have commercials
so therefore it's one act
I'm going
okay if whatever floats you about it all
comes out the same anyway see
I'd like to think that that the my
understanding of story structure is not
proscriptive it's descriptive so I just
choose to describe a well-told story
like this somebody else
could choose to describe a well-told
story using different terms and
different terminology I mean everybody
does you know you know Blake Snyder you
know had you know his way of of looking
at a truby you know McKee you know we're
all talking about the same stuff it's
not like it's not like you know if you
looked at you know Star Wars or you know
Avengers end game you know it's like the
movies become different depending on how
you describe the structure of it all so
you know so to me it's it's just it's
kind of a semantic sort of argument just
for my purposes it just it makes things
very orderly
um when you look at it in terms of sort
of the flow of a story you can divide it
into quarters
what are plot points and why are they
important so plot points are
discrete in my understanding right
discrete chunks of information that add
to the overall knowledge of the story so
so for example
um if we had a
um
let's let's say we I'm making I make up
a fictional movie okay and it's like you
know we come up it's you know the camera
pans through you know a Manhattan living
room in you know at right after Sunrise
you know it's been happening because you
can see the Empire State Building out
the window and it ends up on and you see
like there's a music stand you know that
as the camera is moving through this
apartment so you know okay somebody's
into music and then there's an artist
easel so they're into music and also art
and then the camera ends up in this
bedroom and you know and the alarms go
off you know there are two people in bed
and each has their own alarm set for the
exact same time right and you know and
two hands reach out and shut off the
alarms and the guy gets out of bed on
his side and the woman gets out of bed
on her side and they go into their
bathroom and then the camera's just fine
this is either Cuts or you know one
continuous movement however you want to
direct it
um but we see that they're brushing
their teeth at two separate sinks and
then I'm really talking to each other
you know brushing the teeth at two
separate sinks and then they go have
breakfast together he's reading his
newspaper she's reading her newspaper
still not really talking
you know she gets up to go to work and
they have a little kiss it even doesn't
seem bad it just seems like it's a kiss
goodbye she goes off to work and and is
having coffee at some you know Starbucks
and she looks over and there's this
couple clearly in love okay and she
looks at them as they're hugging and
they kiss and she just bursts out crying
right and there's a old woman next to
her and she goes what's the jerk's name
sweetheart and she goes Ben
right so how many plot points was that
it's a true it's a trick question if you
say well it's Manhattan it's the the
artist's easel it's the you know it's
the music stand we saw them in bed and
it's yeah it's one plot point you know
there's this guy and a girl and their
relationship sucks
that's it everything else about that is
necessary to lay some pipe for the story
who somebody's into art somebody's into
music they are living together you know
there's no communication going on but
it's all about they Julie and Ben let's
say her name is Julie Julie and Ben have
a lousy relationship and it's killing
her right so that says plot point so so
plot points don't have to be
it's like there's beats there's scenes
you know then there's plot points so to
me a plot point is you think of like a
like a pearl necklace and plot points is
another Pearl on that necklace and it's
it's not meant to be and and some plot
points could be you know just one one
beat but this plot point I described was
basically
I don't know 14 beats something like
that you know it's probably 14 beats if
you I was writing it as a script it's
probably
seven scenes like the the apartment in
the morning and the breakfast and the
you know like everything would have its
own slug line you know interior Julian
Ben's apartment bathroom interior Julian
Ben's apartment kitchen you know or
Montage but each but when you shoot it
the montages get broken down into so
it's probably seven scenes in terms of
like strict movie making how many plot
points won
right so so that became you know that's
a big part of my understanding of story
is is how many plot points does it take
to tell
a complete an ample story as our friend
Aristotle might say
um and to me the magic number turned
into 44. there's that four again right
turned into 44. yeah right and the whole
getting up to 44 was kind of a weird
sort of exploration anyway it doesn't
have to be 45 43 47 but if you tell me
you know your typical
you know two-hour movie is 85 plot
points they'll be like
I politely disagree it's too much you
know or you're thinking about Beats
maybe you know and not plot points and
and also just just you know for
clarity's sake again it's just
descriptive right it's maybe this is the
part where I'm actually getting
proscriptive because
I believe very firmly and there's the
the film that gets sold in the film that
gets made
so I
am obsessed with the film that gets sold
because that's the one that you write
and you try to get people to Fork over
money for it but that's the one you have
control over that's like yours as a
writer and and that's the one that that
you can really influence once you sell
it like if we go back to the Stanley Cup
story I had no control once once I sold
it
no control over the direction of the of
the story and how would it get Rewritten
and who is going to be in it and what's
the director's take on it
you know so it's like so I'm I'm really
occupied myself with the writing a
script that could get sold
um and
for that you want to tell a story in a
way that the person who will buy it
um can understand it and and that story
can kind of get into their heart and
soul so
to me
44 plot points turned into that's a very
manageable story and following you know
a kind of a
um a guideline of what does a well-told
story look like
um just felt to me like that
that enhances your chances of selling
something because you're telling you're
telling a story in a way that people are
kind of programmed to
hear the story you know which is not to
say that people shouldn't do crazy
ambitious stuff and just like everything
everywhere all at once is crazy
ambitious doing really well I haven't
examined it to see but I can almost
guarantee you even with all that's going
on
um that it you know that it is hitting
it's it's hitting the plot points in in
the right order and in the right places
it just doesn't with crazy wild
imagination right so you know so for me
it's not like every it's not like every
good movie or every every popular movie
has to
follow the system but you know where
every movie written or every movie ever
made follows this exact system it
doesn't right but every movie that that
really kind of
sinks in and gets to people
um pretty much whether it is
intentionally or not is following
something very similar to what I
prescribe
what is the central question a central
question I love I love me a good central
question so a central question not to
sound like I'm quoting but I think I
might be so the central question is the
question that once it's definitively
answered yes or no your story is over
so and Central questions
apply to
screenplays for sure and
even TV series like like a season of a
television show might have a central
question for the TV for That season and
each episode might have its own it has
its own central question for
um you know for each episode so it's a
central question is really just the way
to
make sure that you're hitting sort of
the the emotional and intellectual and
um personal
thrust of the story so so really a good
central question has is really like
three components you know it's probably
like you know I think Sid field called
like professional personal and private
you know um which was this idea that
if you look at like um you know Star
Wars is kind of a classic example that I
use you've ever seen Star Wars okay so
Star Wars um you say what's the the
central question of Star Wars the
professional question is will
um will Luke destroy the Death Star
right the
um
personal question is will he save
Princess Leia
and the private question is will he be a
Jedi like his father
right so if you look at Star Wars you
know the professional personal and
private you go
that all three of those get answered
right at the climax of the movie right
he destroys the Death Star sure he went
in and he saved Princess Leia from the
jail cell but they let him get away
because they would lead him to the rebel
base right and
um
the the way of saving Princess Leia for
real because she's on the planet that
the Death Star is about to destroy right
so the way to save Princess Leia
ultimately is to destroy the Death Star
and the way to destroy the Death Star is
he's got all the technology and stuff
that he's using but he shuts it off and
he uses the force so in one Fell Swoop
right in One Moment In the climax he
uses the force saves the princess by
destroying the Death Star so the central
question is answered in the affirmative
yes yes and yes yeah will he yeah will
he save Princess Leia yes will he
destroy the Death Star yes will he
become a Jedi like his father yes
movies over right so you know it becomes
very easy and and they don't all have to
be answered yes I mean Dark Knight you
know is interesting it's you know if I
recall the central question of Dark
Knight properly it's you know it's will
will
um Bruce Wayne get the girl is the you
know is the uh you know personal
question right will you fall in love you
know have a relationship with Rachel
professional is will he stop the Joker
and the private is can he can he be the
hero that Gotham City
needs right you know Kenny rise to that
challenge so you look at it goes well
yeah he defeats the Joker but he doesn't
get the girl right he he loses her and
he becomes it's the great line it's the
it's it's the he becomes the hero that
Gotham doesn't want but Gotham does need
so he does become the hero but not in
the way that he was expecting it so and
that's part of what why Dark Knight is
such a brilliant movie because it it's
very clear on the central questions but
it doesn't it doesn't give you the the
happy ending kind of walk off into the
sunset kind of uh of conclusion
what is the central question for
stitchers
I have to think about that I know I
wrote it once
well the the original it's it's
it depends because central question is
often defined by
the your central character
um like a good central question is is
about like in The Dark Knight
you know example it's about Bruce Wayne
Batman right that's and in Star Wars
it's about Luke so essential question is
really a function of whoever your main
character is right so for for stitchers
without main character being you know
cursed and who had this made up you know
you know illness is temporal dysplasia
you know which which made her like you
know a person who like has like she's in
a lives in a constant state of deja vu
like everything seems immediately
familiar to her right so the the
professional question is will she become
a part of this government lab because
she's very kind of recruited to solve
help solve a murder even though they've
kind of had her eye on her for a while
so will she become part of this team
that would be like the professional
question the personal question is
um will she be able to develop a
relationship with the male lead you know
Cameron and then the private question is
will she
um really discover what happened to her
you know her mother because there's this
like whole mystery like the mom is
presumed to be dead but isn't really and
I mean there is a way to look at the
central question like how do you know
what's a good central question so the
professional part of the central
question is the thing that means a lot
to a lot of people and the personal part
means a lot to a few people and the
private means a lot to one person
so so going back to Star Wars for did
you see Star Wars so going back to start
I believe that we're just gonna keep
doing that job so going back to Star
Wars
destroying the Death Star means a lot
that's a professional question it means
a lot to a lot of people right it's
blowing up planets it's everybody in the
entire galaxy far far away once the
deaths got destroyed so destroying the
Death Star means a lot to a lot of
people will Luke save the princess means
a lot to a few people certainly means a
lot to the princess it means a lot to
the rebels I don't know that saving the
princess means a lot to somebody on some
Planet you know far you know on the
other side of the Galaxy right it
doesn't mean a lot to everybody so it
means a lot to a few will Luke become a
Jedi like his father means a lot to Luke
so so that's a good way to look at your
your central question like what means a
lot to a lot of people a lot to a few
and a lot to one and then that's a good
way to kind of Define your central
question and it helps Focus your your
main character because everybody's kind
of obsessed with you know
character-driven stories and stuff like
that which sounds odd because I I
always approach my stories from a plot
heavy stance first rather than you know
rather than character your character
comes
later in some weird way I know um this
is like controversial and people will
think that you know I'm an idiot or will
wildly disagree with me about it you
know it's like I'm I'm
espousing some like satanic approach to
storytelling what plot first character
second
I don't know maybe maybe it's because I
like like characters pop into my story
head kind of fully formed so I don't
worry about them
as much as I worry about telling the
getting the plot right
um so yeah it's it's kind of it's sort
of a double-edged sword you know I I
stopped myself I was going to say
something controversial like like
if you have a really well told story
with a poorly constructed main character
you might very well
still sell that because somebody looking
and go oh here's what this character
needs to do to better serve this really
well constructed story
so so because you're going to get notes
and you're going to get Rewritten and
stuff like that so if you have a
fundamentally really strong really solid
story but there's some character flaws
in the development of those characters
not character flow like you know they
steal or something like a character flaw
in your construction of that character
um you might still very likely sell that
story
um and then work on the character
afterwards but if you have a really
poorly constructed story but it has a
great character
I don't know I don't know if you're ever
gonna sell that it's just it's too much
it's too much of a heavy lift
you know it's I I I I I know maybe I'm
wrong I'd love to hear from people who
have maybe had that experience but to me
with everything I know about the
business and about marketing and about
selling and about what people want or
don't want
it feels to me like it's a much safer
bet to have a strong story with a
character that could use a little bit of
work if the character is terrible I mean
then it's you know but if you're within
spitting distance of a well-constructed
character who's in a really well
constructed story that's far better than
you know you're you know having a
perfectly constructed main character who
saddled with this just useless story
is the central question also a story
engine
um
yes and no it's a story engine to the
extent that it it helps create certain
parameters by which you should tell the
story
um but it's a it's really a litmus test
more than anything else the first main
purpose of the central question is to
Define where Act One ends and where act
two begins because
your your act one is laying all the pipe
for the rest of your story it's the
foundation of the house so your central
question comes in at the end of act one
and I don't mean it comes in like you
know somebody brings in a box and they
go here's your central question but your
your essential question should be
clearly defined at the end of act one
you know so like at the end of act one
in Star Wars again did you see so at the
end of act one in Star Wars
you know um Luke is had his aunt and
uncle killed he's they know that the
princess is in trouble
um Obi-Wan has said you must come with
me if you want to be a Jedi like your
father you know
um and because you know I can't I gotta
go you know milk the space cows or
whatever so you know and then he goes
back home and realizes that news and now
he's got nothing to hold him there and
he comes back and goes there's nothing
to keep me here I want to go with you I
want to save the princess I want to be a
Jedi like my father and that's the end
of act one you know as they're about to
go down into you know Moss Eisley in the
bar and the great you know Cantina scene
um but all those we we know very clearly
what his professional personal and
private Journey now is going to be
through the rest of the story and that's
the landmark that's the the flag that
the Storyteller waves to say act one is
now over it's now time for act two so
you can use as a writer you should use
the central question to help Define your
switch over from act one to act two and
if it's not clear it's like you know I
don't know what my character's main
mission is going to be in the story and
by Mission I don't mean that you got to
go over the restaurant the mission could
be a love story right Mission could be a
medical drama it's like whatever that
professional thing the thing that means
a lot to a lot of people
um that should be clear as should be
that your main character's personal
desire and then the private need of the
character and once that's all clear
that's the end of act one I I can't tell
you the number of
scripts I've consulted on where it's
like you just read it and you're on page
you know 75 and it's still not clear
what your character needs to accomplish
and you go oh my God it's like this is
like a never-ending act one there's so
much fat in there
um yeah so that central question is a
really good litmus test to for you to
say Have I told my Act One properly
that's like building a house if you know
I build have I built my Foundation
properly yep professional personal
private yep done good let's move on now
to the first floor of the house right
you don't want to build the first floor
on a faulty foundation so it's it's a
good test for that and then
to go to your question of story engine
it's you just it's a story engine only
in that you go oh I got a really great
idea for a scene and you start writing
out that scene you have to ask yourself
is this am I re if am I answering
the central question definitively yes or
no on the professional
storyline the personal storyline or the
private am I moving that part of the
story forward you know in some new way
and if you're not then then it's
probably the wrong scene or beat or
moment because you're not advancing the
story based on the central question so
essential questions not really a story
engine it's just it's that mirror that
you can hold up to your to your story so
that you have a sense of am I am I
satisfying I made my audience a promise
with the central question
everything that comes afterwards has to
honor that promise I promised I would
tell them the story of Luke becoming a
Jedi like his father I promised that I
would tell the story of Luke saving the
princess I promised I would tell the
story about trying to stop the Death
Star and if you look at the story Every
Beat
is something about one of those three
components and you know if it's like cut
to you know Luke goes to a pet shop and
decides that he wants to buy a dog you
go
it might be the sweetest cutest most fun
scene you know in the history of fun
scenes but you know it's not moving the
story forward
and it's actually just going back to
Star Wars again there's plenty of um of
outtakes and and scenes that were shot
that um that exists that you can find
and just watch those scenes and go oh
that's why I didn't make it into the
finished story okay that because it's
not it's not advancing it's it's not
adding another Pearl to the necklace
it's really just
and you know emphasizing a pearl that's
already there and you go you don't need
it right so yeah it's you've got to be
judicious on it that's kind of like
another reason why because I I've worn
many hats in my career when I started
off in editing
um back in the editing rooms in New York
you know in film and sound editing and
you know I just watched the
the anxiety you know as they they would
get all this footage in and say oh my
God they're so overshot
um and stuff they don't need and like
stuff that gets cut out and cut out and
cut out like everybody knows the stories
of like people's performances end up on
The Cutting Room floor and the first cut
of a movie was four and a half hours
long and they finally get it down to you
know 90 minutes you know who's you know
how much time and money that wastes
um like
it's just crazy so so I'm a fan of Leo
construct a really well told story don't
don't fill it with fluff don't have Luke
going to get dogs because it's not gonna
it's not never gonna make it into the
finished
product anyway
what is the youngin concept of the hero
within and how does it work within
storytelling so
so the holy jungian approach
for filmmakers it feels like it's a bit
of a catch-all bucket
um where you know like everybody
likes to put into young gay and I think
it was very dealt with a lot of like
symbols and hidden meanings and things
like that but in the the most
I think concise and well constructed
version of this came from a the book
hero within
um by a person named carolus Pearson
um I think I think I don't think she's
alive anymore this book's fairly old but
um but you know Carol if you're still
with us I apologize but I I think she
may have passed on but anyway but she
she was a psychologist who wrote a book
as a self-help book
you know what the idea and it was like
the hero within I think it's like six
archetypes we live by and and her idea
was that was that if you can Define
Yourself by one of these six
archetypes which was like you know uh
Warrior Wanderer often martyr innocent
magician here we go I actually got them
all
um so if you so you can kind of Define
Yourself by one of these archetypes
you could then say well I don't want to
be a martyr I want to be a warrior and
then she was able to chart well how does
based on classic literature how did
stories that had orphans who became or
you know Martyrs who became Warriors
what was that Journey like and so she
was sort of interestingly extrapolating
from literature
self-help lessons which is really kind
of interesting like you know like most
people get into writing
kind of Define
you know like I want to be like
you know Bruce Wayne when I grow up I
want to be like you know whatever you
know you know Harry and when Harry met
stuff you know it's like it's like you
start imagining yourself as these
characters she kind of went the other
way she says you know she was kind of
like you know you can you can learn
lessons from those characters and
reimagine yourself you know into a
different character it was kind of like
an interesting approach so
um so for her it was it was a self-help
manual
um and which kind of described sort of
the history of literature and I think it
was like literature and poetry and um
theater that she was she was pulling her
information from
um I mean I
tripped upon it from a friend of mine
who's a very gifted writer who
um who got kind of uh shafted by one of
the writer's Guild strikes you know kind
of like just cut him off at the knees at
a certain point
um but brilliant mind brilliant writer
great insights into storytelling a lot
of a lot of the
the things that I understand about story
came from this ongoing conversation I
had with him his name is Gilbert Evans
and uh and so very much the
you know a lot of my whole approach to
storytelling was based on this ongoing
conversation Gil and I would have back
and forth about oh I just realized this
oh I just realized this and we would
like kind of share this information and
he had stumbled across this book
um you know the um the hero Within
and and I I like clearly remember this
conversation and I'm talking about like
1997 to 1998 you know somewhere around
there where um where um
Gill calls me up and goes I just
discovered this really cool book called
The Hero within it's got these six
archetypes and I was looking at some of
the movies that I really like and I
noticed that the main character moves
through four of the six archetypes like
clockwork
I was like really so you're saying yeah
it's like act one the main character is
an orphan of some kind either a
figurative orphan or a literal often
orphan so the main character is an
orphan of some kind in act one act two
they become a Wanderer
um then we'll we'll tie it back to the
central question at some point but act
two they become a Wanderer act three in
my Forex structure they become a warrior
in act four they become a martyr it's
like wow it's really interesting it
can't possibly be true but it's really
interesting and I started looking at
movies and stories and going oh my God
it is true like every well-constructed
story the main character goes through
these four archetypes like clockwork
um you know and it's it just became like
this it almost became like the it's like
one of the defining cornerstones of you
know of um of my whole understanding of
story was that like so many things kind
of like fell into place as a result of
understanding those four archetypes
um even to the point where you know like
one of the earliest
kind of aha moments I had was talking to
an exec at Disney
um who I pitched some story I don't
remember what it was anymore but I
pitched him a story and he went yeah
that was okay but your story you know
didn't answer the four Central questions
I was like okay what what might those
four Central questions be and it's like
who's your main character you know what
are they trying to accomplish who's
trying to stop them and what happens if
they fail
right so so suddenly you went you know
understanding the archetypes suddenly
start
Ed to shed some light on the the central
question not Central questions the uh
you know the four questions of of the
film like who's your main character it's
on the orphan what's he trying to
accomplish that's Wanderer right you
know who's trying to stop them right
that's Warrior because somebody's trying
to stop you you're going to stop them
back that's Warrior and what happens if
they fail that's martyr so it's like
suddenly like everything started folding
in on itself
you know that these archetypes started
now relaying relating to you know the
four main questions of uh you know of
your story which then started relaying
into the four acts of the of the
structure that I had you can now start
saying oh well act one is who's your
main character and orphan you know act
two right and it's just everything just
started like like lining up really
really neatly as a result of that so
um you know I think this probably was
all sorts of reasons that really smart
people know why it works that way I was
just happy that it worked you know it's
like like I don't need to understand the
schematic to my microwave to you know
fill out a piece of chicken I'm just
happy it does it when I've hit the fill
up button so there's probably people out
there with a much more intellectual and
academic understanding of exactly why
this works I'm just happy it does
and I think there's also a school of
thought that you know in each of these
archetypes that we all possess or all of
our characters possess that there's a
dark and a light to them and and how
that could be a hindrance or helpful in
the story to your character's Journey so
right
um you know you could say the warrior is
is brave but also the warrior could also
start fights and and and it could cause
problems
um the innocent could be uh charming and
sweet but also it could be taken
advantage of you know so there's
different things that yeah absolutely
right and that and that and that
actually plays in with uh the unity of
opposites which is like a whole nother
you know part of it you know that whole
idea that that is you you want to have a
layered character you you want to have
characters that that are not just
one-dimensional I mean you can you know
and and those are those are perfectly
fine characters and they live in
perfectly fine stories
um where it starts getting interesting
though right is the difference between
you know Bruce Wayne in the in the Dark
Knight versus Luke sky Skywalker and
Star Wars right so it's it's this you
know you you get a more complex
character but you know but there's a
question that comes with that is that
people sometimes will overly complicate
a character just for the sake of overly
complicating them and and then the
pieces don't hold together right you
want to be able to you want to be able
to like really understand why a
character does what they do like I'm not
even necessarily talking about like
anti-heroes or like a good example
because by their very nature but but you
you want to have these layered complex
characters you know Walter White yeah
from Breaking Bad was a brilliantly
complex character right you know which
was just by itself like a brilliant
piece of Storytelling you know you have
a Vince Gilligan the um the idea how do
you how do you take
like I think even he said like we want
to take Mr Chips and turn him into
Scarface right so that idea of how do
you take a guy who's just a family man
and he's dying of cancer and he's a high
school chemistry teacher and a really
really good guy and turn him into this
brutal drug lord right that's a complex
character and all those pieces were kind
of there from the beginning they just
like slowly
made themselves known to the the
audience as as the series progressed
right so you don't want to just have
like my character is this right my
character is that there's um
there's a I don't remember who came up
with it but of course it was probably in
conversation with Gil Evans that that we
started talking about it is you know is
use the term like accept when right so
like um Woody from Toy Story you know is
you know is the you know is the
friendliest
best toy and leader
in the entire history of toys except
when his relationship with Andy gets
threatened
right for the goodness what happens with
Buzz Lightyear Buzz Lightyear throws up
and threatens but Woody's relationship
with Andy now we see a whole other side
of Woody so you can take your main
character and say this is who my
character is except when this thing
happens and then that and that's a
trigger to explore another aspect aspect
of the character and with Walter White I
think we we start to see him just become
this other person a hundred percent of
the time where it slowly starts with a
car wash and then buying the jeans and
seeing his son bullied and and you start
to see it bubble out yeah but but it's
not there yet and then finally it's full
on and there's no turning back yeah yeah
it's kind of interesting like uh it's
just doing on me now it's like another
fantastic movie with complex characters
was uh Unforgiven like the Clint
Eastwood movie from
okay is it 20 years ago by now 30. it's
a long time but yeah a terrific terrific
you know Oscar winning screenplay but
you know but Clint Eastwood's character
of of Bill or William Money I guess was
his name
um
had this horrible past but we don't know
about his horrible past until we see him
in in the present as this kind of
bumbling inept kind of broken Rancher
his wife is dead you know and he's
losing his abilities like you know he's
trying to he was like he was trying to
shoot and be like when he's thinking
about going on this mission to raise
some money to save the farm
you know you try shooting at some cans
you know you know in the distance with
his pistol and he can't hit him and he
like goes inside his kids are watching
him kind of like unimpressed he goes
inside and grabs a shotgun because now
he could at least hit it with the
shotgun so he's you're seeing this guy
who's like past his Prime and and it's
only as the story progresses you go oh
my God this was the most notorious
killer in the west you know who
who settled down and foreswore his
bad ways and is now coming back
right I mean it's it's kind of a very
interesting story arc but um but uh
you know but he's not
but none of that is obvious
at first right when you first meet
Walter White it's not obvious what he's
going to turn into when you first meet
you have no money it's not obvious what
he's going to turn into so you know it's
I I always found that stuff to be very
inspirational as far as like developing
a character and you know taking them on
that journey and how do you how do you
layer in stuff like that you know and
and build it out
but um and they're also the tricks and
techniques to how to define that but um
yeah I love that stuff
why is it important for the main
character of a story to be sympathetic
well this is controversial
um
it's a sales technique
I I mean I hate to kind of put it like
that but again I'm obsessed with stories
that get sold because like anybody
who's listening to this who might want
to write something
um
I mean I guess there are people out
there I've run into them who they're
like oh I don't care if I sell anything
I'm just satisfying this artistic urge
and you know more power to them but
you know but I'm like you know like I'm
a father I'm a grandfather I've got four
kids I got three grandkids I've you know
I've got a mortgage I've got expenses
like people it's expensive to be alive
and if you want to really devote
yourself to screenwriting I want
and somebody's coming to me for advice I
want to give you advice that can move
the needle and and try to help you not
just achieve your goal of writing a
script like I I not anybody can write a
script but almost anybody can write a
script getting a script sold is a whole
nother skill set so for me the idea of a
sympathetic main character
makes your script more salable
so it's because people I don't care what
people say though yeah I like good
anti-heroes yeah whatever it's like yeah
at the end of the day the vast majority
of people want characters that they can
empathize with that are sympathetic that
you're rooting for them to achieve their
goal right that you know that's really
kind of what I mean by sympathetic it's
like you you want this character to
to achieve what it is they're setting
out to do you're rooting for them
because now you're emotional you as the
audience you're now emotionally invested
in the story
um I was just watching something what
was it I was just watching something the
other night
I wish it didn't it doesn't stick in my
memory because it had this this flaw is
that you're watching the movie and where
um I really wish I could remember what
it was now
um and where
two-thirds three quarters of the way
through the movie it wasn't a TV show is
a movie and I look at my wife and I go
do you care what this character is up to
and she's like no I go yeah me neither
it's because the character
just wasn't sympathetic is like there
was nothing there for us to root for I
didn't want them to achieve their goals
right so you know so it was just
you know kind of like one of these
things where it's like yeah it got made
obviously and I mean things get made all
the time for all sorts of reasons but
but if you want to break into the
industry you know you want to you want
to try to stack the deck in your favor
as much as possible
and just in my experience
trying to sell a script with a
sympathetic character is a much better
business plan
than trying to sell a script with and
unsympathetic character and
I will all throw a caveat on that is
that you also
you don't have to make every
you want to sell selling a script and
having a career are two entirely
different things right completely like I
I would
I mean
and I'm not bad mouthing them because
the the you know they're at all but you
look up you know if you look up sort of
the career trajectory of
um you know I think uh Jeff Arch who uh
who wrote Sleepless in Seattle right
um the original of it you know which
which you know kind of got you know got
Rewritten by Nora Ephron but you and
then you look up the career Arc of um of
Len
forget his last name but he's the one
who wrote cable guy who started that
whole
sort of like domino effect of spec
screenplay sales you know kind of back
in the day where he was one of the
people as part of it
um it could have been Shane black who
started the the the thing at in the mid
90s but um but Len I like it on his name
there's one look up on IMDb and you'll
see that that it that's selling those
scripts which were great well cable guys
not a great script but it did it did you
know get made you know but it it didn't
it didn't translate into career
security right so so the goal is not to
just sell a script the goal is to have a
career so so there's kind of almost like
a two-part kind of thing with this is
that you if you can sell a script you
you're better off
trying to sell that script with a
sympathetic main character but there is
something else to be said to write a
script that's unproducible and it's
going to sound strange and it very
contrary to everything else I'm saying
because an unproducible script becomes
memorable in some weird way so it's like
that's part of building the career this
is part of feeding your family right so
you you can do both and this is also why
you you I I you know I say you'll like
make a derivative and make it fast you
know why going back to my if it if it's
taken you a year to write a script
you're not going to make it because if
you can bang out two of these scripts
yeah like he doesn't want the really
sympathetic character and here's one
that is this crazy script that's kind of
unproducible but super memorable
um and you can do both of those in six
months you're building up this like oh
my God this guy's this this person has
got depth and interesting things going
on right but I'm gonna buy this one but
I'm not going to forget this one right I
I I got and this is a advice I got from
a producer who's telling me that that
somebody and I had this advice everyone
was doing research for my book
um I was I was doing interviews with
producers and this producer gave me this
advice about about everybody every every
writer who wants to have a career should
write something that's completely
unproducible
um and he gave the example of he had a
script about whatever right completely
unproducible nobody would ever make this
movie but many years after this producer
read that story he goes I never forgot
that writer I never forgot that
screenplay I'm relaying this story now
right like
yeah I don't know how many years later
20 years later and I remember this story
so so it makes you memorable which is
what helps
build your career
um but you want to also feed the
families that's why you get to like the
sympathetic character part so you can
write have your own sympathetic
characters you know or you know you are
I mean I'll tell everybody that look you
know you want to have your little you
know you know artsy fartsy
you know interesting screenplay great
write it after you've got some money in
the bank because you sold something that
people wanted
you know it's yeah so that's to me
that's why sympathetic works
do you think that's sometimes a deciding
factor in in how far someone will go is
that they think oh that I'm selling out
but really it's a necessary I don't want
to call it an evil but it's a necessary
part just as as showing up on time or
whatever you know I don't know yeah
selling it out I don't know what selling
out even means to be honest I mean I
hear it a lot it's like I don't want to
be a sellout it sounds like an excuse to
me it's like well obviously unless
you're living in your parents basement
you know and you don't need money or
you're independently wealthy then that's
fine do whatever the hell you want but
assuming you want to make money at this
thing that you're telling me you want to
make money at then you're not selling
out you're just being smart right it's
like
I don't know like if somebody wants to
open up a pizza shop and you know and
there's the absolute best brand of
tomato sauce that everybody uses you
know and everybody every pizza shop that
uses this tomato sauce
you know everybody says oh the pizza is
so delicious and you go I'm not gonna
use that pizza sauce I'm selling out I'm
gonna be different I'm selling out okay
fine good luck with your pizza pizza
shop you know I mean it's like so I
don't know what selling out means I'm
I'm too busy trying to put food on the
table to worry about selling out and I
think everybody are so I encourage
everybody move off of that right just
don't hide
I know I'm sounding like really angry
I'm very angry right now don't hide
behind expressions like
selling out to cover up for your
your
current inability to earn a living at
what you're trying to do
um learn the skills and and work on it
and you know
you know read books and watch movies and
join
you know online you know uh groups or
even you know meetups you know and get
together with people who love
storytelling and movies as much as you
do and and don't take no for an answer
and keep just saying why did that work
and somebody says oh I think it worked
like this and you say no Schechter
you're wrong tell me again tell me you
can explain it prove to me you know like
really approach it
you know approach like every other
profession where people you know like
you know are earning money and and being
professionals at what they do and don't
treat it like a hobby you know and you
know it's like I don't know you know it
was it do doctors say oh I don't want to
be a sellout you know dude I didn't do
real estate agents to you know maybe
maybe they do people on Wall Street
you know selling out maybe I don't know
but um but in in this profession it's
just like
got to take care of business you know so
how important is it for the antagonists
to be unsympathetic well in
my kind of balancing out of the forces
in a story they have to be wildly
unsympathetic but they have to believe
that they're sympathetic right this is
so it's a it's a bit of a distinction
it's not even a subtle distinction right
they they believe that they're the hero
of Their Own Story
so they maybe go I misunderstood I'm
doing something for the greater good and
just you people are too stupid to
realize that
um but they come off as
wildly unsympathetic as a result of it I
mean you want your bad guy I mean
stories
feel to me like they have to deal in
extremes because otherwise why are we
watching it like like oh look it's a
family that's you know sitting together
and they have polite conversation around
the dinner table or you know it's like
that's going to be far less interesting
than who's afraid of the junior wolf you
know where it's just fireworks from you
know from these two families you know
these two couples you know for two hours
right so it's like that's why I think
why stories exist is to live in the
extremes to make you
feel things that you wouldn't have felt
in your normal life so that when things
do happen in your normal life you are
somehow
you've experienced it so you're somehow
better able to cope with it there's this
book called uses of Enchantment by Bruno
bettelheim which looked at fairy tales
and and sort of the purposes of fairy
tales and a lot of the the whole history
of fairy tales was designed as horrible
stories that you told your kids because
the world was an incredibly scary place
so by by telling these stories it would
prepare kids for these potentially
catastrophic things that were inevitably
going to happen so things like
um
um like what's like a Little Red Riding
Hood where
you know she gets into bed with the wolf
you know and it's the Red Cloak I mean
it's it's all about losing one's
virginity you know others according to
Bruno bettelheim you know in in uses of
Enchantment and even things like like
you know like nursery rhymes you know
um you know ashes ashes We All Fall Down
that was because of the black plague you
know that the the ashes were from the
burning bodies you know and we all fall
down you know it's because they thought
that the plague was maybe carried by Ash
and smoke and stuff so it was like you
know so so stories had this had this
purpose of
and even Aristotle talked about it to
create within you these very extreme
emotions so that you felt like you went
through that so that at some point in
your life
if you're faced with a challenge similar
to what you've experienced by watching a
well-told story
um you are somehow you've got some
emotional inoculation against against
being devastated by these horrible
things that happen because you've kind
of experienced it through somebody else
somebody else's Journey meaning your the
character in a story which is another
reason why
you go back to the idea of a sympathetic
character because if I'm going to learn
the the lesson in the extreme from a
character I have to
sympathize with that character or
empathize with that character I have to
feel that character very deeply and that
will benefit me as just a human being
because I've now experienced that
emotion from that story more completely
which if we go by the the Bruno
battleheim aristotillion version of the
purpose of story makes me a better human
or a human better able to cope with
challenges in my life so I mean so to me
like storytelling is such a noble
purpose
um if you look at it that way
um
you know that the this whole idea that
you know that
you you need the sympathetic character
and the Really unsympathetic main
character so you can experience
life at the most extreme edges rather
than the top of the bell curve where you
know everything is kind of fine and
normal right you want to feel the you
know the exhilaration of the of a
sympathetic character
overcoming challenges and you and you
want to feel the danger and the the the
tension
um of a
unrelenting very unsympathetic
antagonist at The Other Extreme so
because that's going to make the victory
that much better you know and then
therefore the emotional connection that
much better and therefore my ability to
cope with things as a human being
emotionally that much stronger so yeah
so to have like sort of characters that
are straddling the fence it could be a
perfectly fine story but it to me it
doesn't fully satisfy that sort of noble
purpose of Storytelling
unless they drastically change let's say
drastically in one end right yeah but
you still right but you still want to
have but but yeah be careful with those
drastic changes because you know you
don't want it to feel artificial
right that you know you you you know
look I think we all
there's a balance between compassion and
Justice and you want
you know if you've got like a really bad
villain
do you want them to see the light or do
you want them to have the snot kicked
out of them right so it's challenging as
a human being because as a human being
you say well you know look we have to
love people we have to have right but
you know if if we're gonna tell the
fictionalized story of Hitler do we want
the big climax to Hitler you know for
Hitler going oh my god I've been wrong
all this time I'm so sorry you know
Hitler goes on his apology tour and he
really feels badly and he starts
adopting orphans and he's just the best
damn
we have stepfather adoptive father
you've ever
no I want I want him dead I want you
know he needs to be punished for what he
did right so and I don't think that it's
indicative of a faulty Humanity to want
to see really bad people brought to
Justice and even if that Justice Means
having this not kicked out of him
you know I was just thinking just Tom
Hanks has almost always played a
sympathetic character except in Elvis I
don't know there might be other ones
Elvis He was definitely a darker
character oh okay okay there you go yeah
um and and it's it's on the top of my
head because it's it's famously so few
roles right almost Harry Fonda I mean if
everybody lost their minds when he
played the the psychopathic villain in
Once Upon a Time in the West okay right
because Henry Fonda was On Golden Pond
yeah yeah you know he was like he was
the every man yeah he's like the Jimmy
Stewart you know it's just this right
you know everybody loves you know he's
just this you know and then he takes
this role as truly the psych of Frank I
think there's a character named a
psychopathic wow you know villain you
know but what's interesting is that like
like had you cast Adolf Hitler in that
role you go yeah yeah we expect that you
cast Henry Fonda and suddenly it's
emotionally much more driven because you
have such an association with Henry
Fonda as everybody's dad sure right sure
it's like it's the Fall From Grace is
you know you drop something from an inch
it doesn't make much of a noise you drop
something from yeah 10 feet and it makes
a
you know effect has a big thunk so
that's the thing with these characters
you know it's like they play against
type sometimes
what is the biggest mistake you see
writers make with the antagonist
I think the biggest mistake I I see
often with the antagonist is that the
antagonist is not
committed
to their goal like they they want their
goal but they're not committed to it
um and the way the way to become
committed to it is to believe 100
percent in the correctness
of the goal so so you can have a car you
can have an antagonist who is you know
driven to do
things but but if it just feels like
they're doing it because they have
nothing else going on or they they have
to be really like really committed to it
really wanting it I mean like going back
to Star Wars you know the like the you
know the emperor is the ultimate
antagonist he believes he's not just
being evil for the sake of being evil
he's he thinks he's bringing peace and
order to the uh to the to the Galaxy
like without his agenda you know it's
he's like he's the ultimate believer and
you got to break a few eggs if you want
to make an omelet you know if he doesn't
if he doesn't do what he's going to do
the the entire universe will fall into
into you know some sort of state of
you know of total chaos you know where
he says okay look you know maybe I have
gotta I've got to destroy a couple of
planets to achieve my my goal but if I
don't even more planets will get
destroyed because there'll be such chaos
you know you know it needs like a firm
hand you know on the uh you know on you
know ruling the universe so so he has to
believe that yeah yeah people are not
going to like my methods but now but
give it some time and people will right
and that's just one example of a you
know of a uh of a character that was so
interesting about
um about Joker going back to Dark Knight
was that
he can he was just representative of
chaos and and he knew he was
representative of chaos and the
brilliant part of the storytelling there
was that everybody else was trying to
figure out what is it that he's
committed to everybody understands
storytelling like in in Gotham City you
know when trying to look at the Joker
everybody is like well you can't he's
he's they're not actually having this
conversation it's like well he's clearly
the antagonist of our life right now
what is he really committed to what does
he really want we have to be able to
negotiate with him or or talk to him or
or yeah well how do and and you know and
he he fledged or you know brilliantly
it's like he goes do I look like I have
a plan he goes like I'm I'm like a dog
chasing a car I wouldn't know what to do
with it if I caught it right but
everybody else is is trying to you know
to scribe some kind of agenda to him
because they know that your antagonist
is supposed to be really committed to
something he's not he's just committed
to chaos right so it was if it is kind
of fascinating stuff you know as far as
like trying to look at it you know like
what do people really want
it seems like especially in the Joaquin
Phoenix version of The Joker he was
really committed to fixing the
Brokenness in himself but he didn't even
know it was fixing it he's trying to
alleviate the pain I guess in some sense
yeah not to excuse what he did but he
was so broken and so misunderstood and
so that seemed to be what his choices
were all based on right yeah for sure
it's be interesting that you know they
just announced the um you know the Joker
sequel is coming out you know you know
Folia do I think it's called which is
kind of like cool so it's going to be
him and and Harley Quinn who's not going
to be Margot Robbie
um who did they just cast this uh Harley
Quinn but yeah people were kind of like
oh it's a different take on it all but
was but but Joker's sort of an
interesting
case because because I'm not convinced
and not just me I think a lot of people
are not quite convinced that the entire
story of Joker isn't taking place in his
own head like in the Asylum so in that
in that kind if if that's the conceit
um then
you know kind of it's almost like all
all rules are off but I think but I
think you're right I mean in at least
the Joker's mental version if it is
indeed just all taking place in his in
his own mind
um then yeah he's very broken and is
trying to cope with being broken in the
best way possible you know and find
Value in himself for you know for that
you know hence the whole like story with
you know with um you know the the woman
you know lives in the apartment and her
kid and you know so it's um yeah but
it's an interesting definitely an
interesting and sympathetic right he is
the main character yeah it's like you
see you know it's
you know proverbial undeserved
Misfortune right all the stuff bad that
happens to him he does not deserve to
happen and sympathetic is like he's
takes care of his elderly mother and you
know it's very sweet with her and washes
her hair you know so it's like but
you know he's
just he's the villain
why is it hard for writers to talk about
theme it's hard for everybody to talk
about theme nobody understands theme I
mean that's a horrible thing to say that
nobody understands theme like oh as if I
understand it's just theme is so complex
and so it's like ethereal it's like it's
the proverbial trying to nail Jello to a
wall trying to understand theme it's
like you know
the
you can get all intellectual about it
and I and I already regret saying like
nobody understands this thing because
I'm sure there are people out there who
teach in you know in college level
courses you know and and deal heavily
with theme and they can talk very
intelligently about theme
um I don't care because I don't know
that that this super super intellectual
understanding of theme helps you write
one damn word again I want people to
have careers I want people to put money
on their table your money in their
pockets and food on their table and you
know you get all
highfalutin and you know ethereal
talking about themes and how they
interrelate with the it's like okay well
you talk about that for a while but why
don't you write something so I I so for
me I I just try to figure out okay I'm
not that smart I just want to figure out
what's the simplest
understanding of theme possible that
will help me write
you know a a story and and that's kind
of where I stumbled across the this idea
of
you know you know it's defining theme
very simply as you know Heroes
ask questions and villains make
arguments
and and that was kind of it I know I
know it seems a little bit strange and
simplistic to do it but but that's kind
of the the way to approach it you know
where it's like there's sort of it and I
guess is a classic basis for it where
it's like you know thesis antithesis and
synthesis right so you know so you know
you go to
um let's see what's a good one
trying to think you know this idea of
trying to think like a really good
example
for theme where you know where
um okay let's we'll use Star Wars again
okay so the theme you know from a
big view is science versus technology
what's more powerful science versus
technology right it's just a thing you
can have all sorts of themes you know is
love love for family better stronger
than love for the Universe I don't know
you know so you can come up with
anything you want whatever helps you
tell the story go with it right don't
don't think there's got to be one
absolute so for me I want the theme the
the accessible thing that I could hang
my hat on to tell a story in Star Wars
for theme is you know it's science
versus technology right and then you go
okay Heroes you know make ask questions
what's stronger you know science versus
technology you know Faith the force
versus you know versus you know Jedis
versus the Empire right you know you
know with Empire representing technology
right the Death Star is a big ball of
Technology you know as compared to the
you know the Jedis which is you know
little you know a vanishingly small
group of people who are involved in
faith right so so Luke asks not verbally
but this is Luke's thematic journey is
what's more powerful he goes I don't
know what's more powerful science versus
or technology I don't know so he's going
to spend the whole story pondering that
um the if you ask the you know the
you know Emperor or Darth Vader or
general you know you know governor of
Tarkin you know on a death star like
Technologies you know Vader has an
appreciation for for Faith but he
himself is a product of Technology Luke
is asking the question what's more
powerful Faith or technology and he
grapples with that throughout the entire
story right everything is about you know
is about that
um the all the bad guys have no such
questions they make the argument
technology is strong like Darth Vader is
a result of Technology he had faith and
it didn't
save him back when he had his fight with
Obi-Wan
so Faith let him down he's now surviving
based on technology the Death Star is a
giant ball of flashy blinky technology
right it's like you know the faith is
gone from the universe right you my
friend are all that's left of you know
your faith or whatever you know whatever
is said to him
um so the bad guys have no such
questions they are convinced they make
the argument that that technology is
stronger than faith Luke is uncertain
and what does he learn finally at the
end is that faith and Technology can
work together right and that's where you
get the ultimate strength right because
he uses
he uses when he destroys the Death Star
he shuts off the targeting computer
which is him rejecting technology use
the force Luke right he's embracing
Faith but it's like it's not like he
does one of you know the Obi-Wan two
finger air move and the death star
explodes he still uses technology to
destroy the Death Star he might use the
Torpedoes so he's using technology in in
concert with faith and that's the
strongest of all so it's a really
interesting lesson right that you don't
have to you don't have to reject you
don't have to be Amish right where
you're rejecting technology right and
you don't have to be you know sort of a
scientific atheist where you're
completely rejecting Faith you can be
somebody who's embracing everything that
the world has to offer in terms of both
spirituality and technology and that's
where you get sort of a complete person
so so for me that's how you tell a story
thematically that's that's what you need
so anything more complicated than that
if if you feel like
you know it's like it you know they they
talk about like what was the Brilliance
of of Trader Joe's over Ralphs right so
you go to Ralph's and you want to buy
ketchup right so you go to you look at
the ketchup aisle and you've got 45
types of ketchup right and you just
don't know which one to buy so you
probably go back to the Neil Hines or
whatever it is you're used to buying
Trader Joe's has like one you got two
types of ketchup right so they realize
that that that
it seems like giving people a lot of
choices
is the right thing to do it feels kind
of magnanimous in some weird way but it
leads to
the proverbial you know analysis
paralysis so the same thing with
thinking about theme that people you
know have all these great and I'm not
saying they're invalid they're just not
helpful theories about about theme and
how theme Works in in a story so to me
it's like they all might be right and it
all might be fine and everybody who's
taking a college level course and theme
I wish you the best of luck and I'd love
to talk to you about it over you know
over Tito's one day however
if it doesn't
Empower you to write your story fast
then it's useless
absolutely useless again I'm strict I'm
like if it if it's if it delays you
getting a check
by two weeks that's two weeks wasted so
yeah so I like to go with like what's
the minimum amount of theme you need to
tell a story and the minimum amount I
found over and over again is you know
Heroes ask questions and villains make
arguments
but as a writer incorporate theme into
stories carefully
judiciously
um possibly even subliminally it's like
I
to me it's it's all these things it's
kind of like the pre-flight checklist
that Pilots go through you know and and
I think you just like you keep referring
back to it so it's like all the
principles everything we've talked about
like over the last you know you know
hour or so
um is that all it's just stuff to keep
in mind as you're writing so that if you
get stuck
when you're writing and inevitably you
will you could look at this list and you
know and go oh yeah my my uh my villains
were not emphatic enough about their
Viewpoint about technology you know or
my hero was was too clear
that that faith is stronger you know so
it's like you could you can look at a
scene and you know and
pondered in terms of oh I'm in you know
I'm on page
you know 55 and my central questions are
not clear yet well clearly I've overshot
so let me go back so everything is kind
of a test so for me for a writer to
incorporate the theme it's like you
gotta like live with these Concepts
kind of as a holistic piece right as a
whole and and until you kind of they get
inside your your soul and your it's like
muscle memory right you know that you
know you you have to just story muscle
memory so so to incorporate theme really
just should be as simple as you know you
write a scene with a character and you
don't have to chart it out ahead of time
and say what's what's my thematic Arc in
this particular scene
is it being true whatever the theme is
like Sleepless in Seattle I know we
talked a little bit about that before
it's like Sleepless in Seattle
you know the question is the Thematic
question is you know can love
you know can can the the magic of Love
happen more than once
right that's that's it that's the entire
thematic question right and Tom Hanks
kind of Wonders you know um you know
it's you know like yeah I don't think it
can happen you know I'm pretty sure it
can't happen more than once so he's kind
of willing to sell out you know you know
right so you know it's it's funny you
know I think a way to really understand
the story about it is you know it's you
Tom Hanks is some weird kind of
antagonist in this because he's kind of
convinced it can't happen once all right
you know so you know I guess he's kind
of pondering it at a certain point but
he's sort of convinced it can't happen
once his son thinks it can happen
um and you know and it's really kind of
at some level the main character might
be Meg Ryan who's wondering well you
know if I can meet this guy could could
this magic of Love happen again so you
know there is a way to look at that
story that Meg Ryan is really the main
character and Tom Hanks is the end
antagonist because he's the one who's
really getting in the way of of Love
happening another time right so you know
so the this idea that you just look at
and say you know am I being true
thematically to what these characters
believe and are willing to either
question or fight about
um
that's that's the way to incorporate it
that's just the way to to use it so you
don't want to bludgeon anybody over the
head and you can you can park it I mean
you know I can't tell you how many
screenplays I wrote before I had
anything resembling an understanding of
theme and you know there's
no like
I know there's going to sound a little
strange maybe to put it this way but I
like everybody has a an innate
storyteller
sense and some people it's more
intuitive and some people it's less
intuitive so the reason why we have
people like me talking about how we
approach it is to such is if you're an
intuitive Storyteller you don't need me
you don't need anybody you don't need
Blake Snyder you don't need you know you
don't need you know McKee it might be
interesting to read that stuff but you
don't need any of that stuff because you
just naturally get it
um for those the vast majority of people
who maybe haven't exercised that muscle
and don't and aren't natural
storytellers you can use logic to get to
that place of intuitive storytelling
right it was like for example
you know if there's well you know like
they're they're let's say there's a
flood right they've just had some
flooding like in the you know in the
midwest right so there's some flooding
um and somebody goes okay there's a
flood that means people uh are have lost
their homes that means they don't have
clothes to wear or food to eat that
means they're displaced I have help
right so they've logiced their way to a
place of I have to help there are other
people like oh there's a flood I have to
help like like they just intuitively
know what's needed it's the same with
storytelling right some people are just
intuitive stories that's why there's
some people who like they'll they'll go
you know they'll look at you know not
just mine but anybody's kind of theories
on story structure and go I disagree
with that I I write stories I never read
one of these so yeah because you're a
natural story you me for I know you're
Mozart when it comes to storytelling
right you know sort of you've got that
natural ability for the rest of us who
are salieri you know and who aren't
Mozart we need tools and techniques to
catch up to where you are naturally
right so so I think it's perfectly fine
to you know put them aside Write Your
Story as intuitively as you can and then
just keep going back to it you know go
back to all of it you know it is my
professional personal and private
central question is that clear enough
right in this scene and this is an
extraneous scene do I have a loop going
to buy a dog in the pet shop do I even
need that scene is it sad you know are
my archetypes falling out properly in
the story oh I have my main character
you know being a a warrior you know in
the first scene well that could be fine
but you know but maybe you've cut
the legs out from under him when he
really or her when when they really need
to become a warrior later on you've kind
of diminished the power of this because
you put it here right like you steer
away from right so you can use all this
stuff as
you know a sort of like litmus tests as
you're working on your story to try to
figure out okay why the hell isn't this
working you know because it's very hard
when you're in the middle of a story
it's really hard to know what's working
what's not working why is it not working
is even more important I know it's not
working but I can't tell you why
so so it's really hard so all these
things you know theme included are just
things you can turn to and say oh well
maybe it's the theme so you look at it
from you know or my heroes asking
questions are my villains making
arguments oh they are okay good it's not
working but it's still not working but I
know it's not because the theme is wrong
so maybe it's the archetypes so you know
then you say okay is you know I'm in act
one is my hero of figurative or a
literal orphan no not really oh okay
maybe that's the problem you're not
setting up the main character right so
that's a long-winded way to you you
asked me about theme and I brought in
everything else but it's it but it
everything's all connected no it's it's
all nothing lives in a good story
nothing lives outside of itself if you
can pull something out of a story
doesn't belong there or if you can pull
something out of a story Theory or a
story Structure Theory then it doesn't
belong
and lastly what if someone thinks oh I'm
an intuitive writer good what but what
if they're really you know it's hard for
people to see themselves we all think
for one thing and and the World shows us
that we're not
um so how do we know though I mean I
mean what would what would be the signs
you make money you know or you you start
you know you start showing your script
around to people and you know it's like
like my experience is that is that
whatever the
you know we all know the stories of of
the writers who you know they're working
as a waiter one day and then they've
been writing the screenplay and then
they it's some producer comes in and
they the waiter was so it was so
compelling that she asks the producer oh
you know we've got would you mind taking
it and they read the script and you know
this kind of it's anecdotal but it sort
of happened to uh uh Diane Thomas who
wrote uh Romancing the Stone who
um
well actually I had the the distinct
pleasure of getting to know her she
passed away very young in a traffic
accident but I was upselling computers
at a computer store and she came in this
is in the mid 80s and she came into the
store to like get a first computer and
not as the resident's screenwriting guy
in the computer store you know back in
the days when you know everything's on
floppy disks still so I had a chance to
work with her to help get her computer
set up and teach her you know kind of
how to uh you know how to use the
technology and you know and we became
friendly I would say friends but
certainly friendly as a result it was
very sad when she passed away but but I
think famously she you know she was a
waitress and was working somewhere and
had written Romancing the Stone and
somebody knew Michael Douglas and gave
it to him and he read it and he loved it
and he bought it and you know so so you
might think that that's you like that
you went from here to here you know you
know instantly and people hear those
stories and go oh that's going to happen
to me that's really it's not it's it's
the vast majority of people that I know
who've had lasting careers in the
business it's like whatever the smallest
possible
incremental step forward
that could happen
um is what's going to happen it's like I
I you know I came to La you know when I
was 24 and I had two scripts written one
was better than the other and you know
so you know first I you know I couldn't
get an agent then I got an agent but the
agent was not a good Agent then I got a
better agent you know and I still can
sell any of the screen I'm still writing
scripts and now I've got like four or
five scripts and I still can't sell a
script then I can get a script optioned
great but it's an option for like ten
dollars you know it's like it's like you
know that's whatever the smallest steps
are so so if somebody thinks that
they're an intuitive writer you
certainly might be TR it might be true
but at a certain point
you know you still have to you still
have to earn a living you still have to
make some money so
um so that's to me the ultimate test is
if you're feeding your family then you
know well done you know yeah it's yeah
it's really the same in any Arts like
how many how many artists have we heard
you know who great artists Van Gogh died
penniless right you know intuitive
artist died
nobody wants to wait that long to you
know wait till you're posthumously
recognized as an intuitive writer right
so you might be find out you know write
something if it comes easily to you and
you don't get stuck on page 55 you might
be an intuitive writer you know or if
you get stuck on page 55 you might be an
intuitive writer who got stuck on page
55 you know right so I know that there's
an easy answer but um but ultimately I'm
a market capitalist so the market
announces to you one day that you are an
intuitive writer then you've done it and
the market might announce to you that
you're a logical writer that you've used
logic to replace intuition even better
because now you thought you now you can
you thought your way into it that means
you can think your way out of whatever
problems you run into